hi
my name is weber google i'm a product
manager in cloud spanner
today i'm going to talk about how
customers are future proofing their
business
for global scale and consistency with
cloud spanner
so as part of this talk i'm going to
cover
uh three main areas first and foremost
i'm going to introduce you to cloud
spanner
second we are seeing a lot of momentum
with cloud spanner for our customers and
i'm going to talk about
what customers are using cloud spanner
which
verticals and what are their use cases
and last
i'm going to share some some recent
developments which
we have done in cloud spanner new
features new capabilities which are up
and coming
so we'll talk about that okay
so to get to it uh cloud spanner is a
unique database
basically cloud spanner offers
horizontal scalability
with complete relational semantics
horizontal scale is something which you
would expect from non-relational
databases
which are sharded and everything spanner
does all that in addition to offering
you
asset transactions complete sql support
all the relational
semantics which you expect from a
relational database uh to top it off
uh it's highly available means we are
talking about
five lines of availability in a
multi-regional configuration
it's fully managed and this is something
which uh google built
uh for itself a number of our billion
plus user products
are sitting on top of spanner the use
spanner as the
main database and something which we
have been using
for quite a long time now how do we make
it work
what are the key building blocks for
spanner so there are three main elements
to it
first and foremost it's the google's
network so
spanner is uh synchronously replicated
behind the scenes uh so a network plays
a lot
a lot of role as part of what we offer
to
our customers in terms of latency in
terms of reliability
and having google's network
infrastructure backing cloud spanner
is really important and as you know we
and the google's network infrastructure
is redundant highly available
and a spanner being multi-regional and
and something which
customers are using as a global database
network plays a big role
second is true time so the picture on
the right of the screen as you can
see they are atomic oscillators
and gps antennas this is actually a
picture for one of our servers
in our data centers and basically what
it's showing you is we have atomic and
gps clocks in our data center
and what it offers is to our customers
this gives a global motion of time
for spanner to function on so once
there is a global notion of time in a
for a distributed database
we can promise external strong
consistency
to our customers and this is something
which is extremely important
the ordering of transactions for
financial services for
retail sector and that is something
which we are only able to offer because
of truth
and last night but not the least we have
a very optimized software stack with a
custom practice implementation
automatic resharing based on those and
side of the data
all the magic which makes panel work
so now naturally a question needs to be
asked why cloud spanner what is
what is it so different in in comparison
to a relational database
first and foremost as i already talked
about earlier it's scale
and the scale insurance which customers
get
out of spanner with high availability so
in terms of scale there is literally no
limit and
you can start small and seamlessly scale
that is
very important for a number of use cases
which we'll talk about
in the later part of the presentation uh
second
multi-region with transparent
synchronous replication we are talking
about a one click experience
in setting up a global instance across
multiple
continents uh strong external
consistency which i already discussed
about
pretty much uh us as one box
relational database experience you can
get
from a horizontally scalable cloud
spanner database
there's no concept of planned
maintenance windows
and that's why we are able to offer you
such high availability
uh it's completely managed you can all
also do completely online schema changes
you don't have to take a down time for
that
we have complete separation of storage
and compute this
becomes extremely important for
scalability
so you can seamlessly scale your
workload
because there's no coupling between
storage and compute and you can scale
them independently
we launched managed backups i'm going to
talk a little bit more in detail about
it but they are consistent backups
we also offer cell level concurrency
control which is extremely important for
a database like spanner which
has use cases where customers are
pushing in millions of qps
and cell level concurrency control
really helps
and again we have databases
internally which have uh which are
petabytes plus size and
for a single database so scale both on
the qps side
as well as the storage side
so this is uh just a representation of
some of the key feature highlights again
i'm not going to talk about each one of
them
but these are the different categories
where we continue to innovate and offer
more
features and capabilities to our
customers first and foremost it's the
enterprise and relational capabilities
so i talked about
uh fine-brain concurrency control manage
backups
we have secondary indexes on the
programmability side we continue to
add more client drivers we have eight
which are now in ga
we have complete ddl and dml support
including batch dml
we have commit timestamps which
customers are using it for multiple use
cases
foreign keys which was recently launched
uh local emulator we'll talk
a lot about some of these capabilities
later on as well
and then on the security side
we launch vpc service control access
transparency
uh all the data by default is encrypted
at rest
uh that's something which we offer so a
lot of capabilities which customers
expect from an enterprise database from
a security standpoint
and which not just spanner but gcp
overall is very good at in terms of
monitoring and introspection
we have a lot of capabilities which we
continue to offer
with more uh so we can provide more
view into what your workload is doing
we have open sensors integration cpu
utilization
graph latency graphs a number of those
things
so moving on uh now i talked about
what is cloud scanner what are some of
the
key capabilities which it offers i think
it's important to understand why
customers are choosing cloud spanner
and and for that it's important to know
what are some of the challenges which
customers face today
and how spanner kind of plays a role in
terms of alleviating
some of those challenges so first and
foremost
there are these business challenges for
customers for example
the first one is the capital expense
which
they have to take for some seasonal peak
workloads so let's say you are a
retailer you are planning for your
couple of days of black friday cyber
monday sale
and to pay for all that fixed
infrastructure for just those couple of
days where you might experience
1000 percent scaling is quite a bit so
that is something which goes on on the
books and
and something they are concerned about
with
then the second thing is all our
customers and majority of them
they have global customer base of their
own uh they want to provide a great
experience to their customers
so they have to invest in multi-region
presence which is again not cheap
and last but not the least is the
operational expense which is
exactly related by some of the seasonal
scaling which comes
with the workloads so you have to plan
for that operational maintenance and
everything
so all this ties into the expense but
there is a human element to it as well
because of operations and maintenance
on the technical side a number of
customers we work with are
very concerned about high availability
means in today's day and age
if you are serving your traffic at the
peak time
whether it's a health for health care
it's enrollment season
for retail it's some of those big days
and for financial services uh any other
times when a lot of payments are being
made
high business continuity is needed so
how do you plan for that with
appropriate dr capabilities there should
be absolutely no downtime
it should be able to scale seamlessly
based on the workloads
consistency is extremely important
for example if you are doing a debit and
a credit in a
financial application it's extremely
important that
the ordering of those transactions is
maintained
by the database as part of when it was
done
and if you go back and take a look that
order should
remain the same and again
the global nature of the world which we
live in from a customer-based
perspective
everybody wants to serve their customers
with uh
with low latency and they need a
consistent view of data globally
and last but not the least the solution
which they have needs to integrate with
multiple systems
and whether a database provides those
hooks
so based on the critical capabilities
which we discussed earlier spanner fits
the bill
in all of these and meets the
requirements which customers come to us
so as i mentioned we are seeing a lot of
momentum on spanner
across multiple verticals some of the
some of them
are listed here and uh if we
think from the basically the
differentiators or spanner which is
like extreme scaling high availability
strong consistency of data and ease of
use
it's very easy to understand why all
these use cases are coming to spanner
across
gaming financial services healthcare
media entertainment technology
a lot of technology companies are uh
coming and adopting spanner
and retail so let's just picking up on
from the gaming side if you are a
game developer and you are making a game
you like to start small
and once the game makes it big or you
are the next pokemon go
then you don't have time uh to
re-architect the app for that scale so
spanner allows you to
do exactly uh that that you can start
small
with a with the right schema and then
you can seamlessly
scale from hundreds to thousands to
millions of
queries per second and transactions and
for
data size which can be similarly like in
megabytes gbs or even petabytes
and a lot of customers are using it to
store user profile real-time gameplay
data
a lot of those applications are there
similarly on financial services
extreme high availability external
consistency
all those and definitely ability to
scale is extremely important
and that's why a number of banks
uh are now switching to spanner first
for their online banking and ledger
use cases healthcare we have a number of
big healthcare customers who are
implementing the complete
emr systems on spanner which is
extremely exciting for us to see
the healthcare space with all the
compliance
hipaa pci we are in compliance
we offer that kind of compliance to our
customers so
as long as it's implemented correctly so
healthcare and across a lot of these
regulatory industries we are seeing a
lot of adoption retail technology
so as a next step i'm not going to dive
into each of these use cases but
just a couple of them and discuss them
in detail
so first of all this is a financial
services retail
banking use case uh it this slide
presents the complete solution
architecture for it
so as you can see basically the use case
is
there's this uh traditional retail bank
which
is my which has migrated to spanner in
this
day and age they have an omni channel uh
way for their customers to access the
same financial data and transact with
that
through mobile through web through voice
and even third party
and this is basically just shown at the
top of the slide
and then spanner piece is right there in
this
red rectangle which is the operational
database side
and this is a very common architectural
pattern which we have seen
where spanner connects with gke and
so it can seamlessly scale both uh from
the
client side as well as on the database
side so it's a very typical
uh pattern and then as i was mentioning
earlier it's extremely important that
the database can hook up with the legacy
systems or
other systems which are there for
example the other core banking systems
which are there or payment gateways as
shown at the bottom and then as the data
is getting updated in the
oltp database which is spanner
the data almost in near real time is
getting
populated in analytics and warehousing
solutions as well
so the customer is able to do their olap
queries and generate insights on that
that is within
bigquery and cloud ai data catalog and
everything so
that whole chain is set up
using pub sub and data flow and on the
security and governance size we
offer all kinds of integration like
cloud monitoring dlp
and customers are able to benefit
with that across the board so this is
just one of those
solution architectures where spanner
plays that operational database role and
is able to seamlessly scale along with
the rest of the architecture
which is extremely critical for our
customers next
uh this is i'm not talking about the
complete
retail omnichannel retail architecture
for this customer
but just focusing on the spanner piece
so in this case the use case was
the omni-channel retail customer is
getting updated prices delivered to gcp
through an external system both as a
streaming data pipeline
as well as in batches the data was being
uploaded
and then spanner was the database of
record for
all the skews with the updated prices
and then spanner
is serving those prices to all the
applications which
this omni-channel retailer is running so
as you can see from the solution
architecture
that the prices are are being uploaded
in cloud storage
and uh then through uh load service
running as part of kubernetes is being
uploaded into
cloud spanner and then cloud spanner is
just
serving all the requests from the
pricing api standpoint
again in this case spanner is getting a
lot of
right load as well as read load and
depending on
the traffic it's able to scale up based
on the needs
of the application and the time of the
day and everything
so again very important and in this case
they were using a multi-regional
instance so
five nines of availability with global
presence and everything
so uh extremely happy with the way it
turned out and custom
and the customer is really uh very happy
with the solution
so switching gears now let's talk about
what's new in cloud spanner
uh and uh and just
a reflection of the past a little bit so
we had a busy 2019 we delivered
capabilities
and three of in in all areas basically
we have categorized in these three major
areas enterprise
capabilities developer productivity and
sql so on the enterprise side
i already talked about vpc access
transparency which is
extremely critical for some of our
regulatory
industry users where when even a google
srd when they touched your data for any
reason
that that kind of an action has to be
locked
so that is access transparency spanner
is uh
supports access transparency and we
updated our sla in september 2019.
basically now all your cloud spanner
instances
uh even with a single node are covered
under the same production sla
so this way uh even for smaller
workloads
you are protected by the same sla which
which we offer
before september 2019 it we used to
require minimum three nodes in an
instance
and the reason we were able to update
our sla is because spanner behind the
scenes is replicated
so even in case of a regional instance
there are three replicas
and we are able to offer you that high
availability uh with a single node
and multi-region x multiple
replicas like five seven and nine
replica configurations is something
which we offer today
on the developer productivity size we
continue to invest in orms
we have launched a new initiative uh and
something which is getting a lot of
momentum called as cloud spanner
ecosystem
uh the website is actually cloud spanner
ecosystem.dev or dev
and because as you noticed we have a lot
of momentum spanner
a number of our customers are
contributing tools
uh in the ecosystem for other spanner
users
and we have a lot of partners
contributing
tools and googlers as well so we created
this ecosystem
as a single place where they can make
their contributions for the benefit of
the overall community and we are seeing
a lot of fraction
please check it out there are a number
of tools which are available
for our users and last but not the least
on the sql side we continue to innovate
for the query optimizer we launched cost
based index selection as part of the
query optimizer optimization we have
html support we launch with clause again
trying to
offer all the capabilities which you
expect from
a database from the sql site
we had a fairly busy 2020 so far
again in those all those three areas we
continue to make
improvements and launch new capabilities
uh
and like manage backup restore i'm not
going to spend too much time here i'll
go into details later
we continue to expand on our
multi-regional configuration options
uh we now we originally had four
multi-regional conf instance
configurations
we recently launched two new
multi-regional
uh configurations one an asia only multi
region and another one in europe
and uh then we recently launched uh a
change watcher solution which is not a
native capability but a solution
which is built on top of uh spanner uh
leveraging the commit timestamp feature
where
customers can watch out for changes
which are happening within the database
and on the developer productivity side
we
emulator is something this is a offline
emulator i'm going to talk more in
details later
but c plus plus client library
transaction statistics
and harbor bridge which is another tool
which we
which was recently contributed in cloud
spanner ecosystem
it is a it is to aid in
migration uh it actually the capability
it provides is
if a customer has a postgresql uh
schema and they use harbour bridge the
tool can recommend an equivalent
spamming schema with it
uh so originally we launched it for
postgres sql support
and with for my sequel we have launched
it in beta
right now and on sql side query
optimizer versioning i'll talk more in
details on that
later and foreign keys so i'm not going
to go into details of each one of these
cable
capabilities but i'll pick one from each
of these areas
and tell you a little bit more about
them
so first and foremost is manage backups
uh which
we launched for with general
availability
in april uh so this is on demand managed
backups
uh this is primarily to offer protection
to our customers against operator
application errors which can cause
logical data corruption
so what we offer is consistent backup
for regional and multi-regional
instances and uh what we are optimizing
for
is uh extremely fast restores our first
time to first by taxes so because if
you run into an issue you would like to
get back online with your application as
soon as possible and we recognize that
so uh even for a backups which is
terabytes of
uh in size you can expect to get first
bet access as part of your restore
process
within minutes so that is something
which we have really optimized for
uh you can restore from your backup
within the same instance configuration
or basically within the same instance or
another instance within the same
instance configuration
and the maximum retention time for
backups is one year
and we from a security perspective we
uh our im access permissions are
separate for backup so
customers have the flexibility to create
a separate role
just to manage the backups and do the
risk tools
so that is there and again the feature
is available through api console gcloud
local emulator so this is something
which we
announced in beta in march
i'm happy to announce the general
availability of local emulator
as part of this uh talk so this is now
generally available we have
uh implemented a lot more capabilities
as part of this general available launch
for local emulator
it is an offline open source local
emulator the code is open
you can take a look it's in a github
repository
it offers complete rest and gp and grpc
api support
and it offers sql basically dml
and ddl support most importantly it has
complete support for information schema
as well
now all client libraries are supported
for working with emulator
and this really we have got great
feedback from a number of our customers
and
it has really helped them from our
productivity developer productivity
perspective
because now they can and do a very quick
correctness testing for their
application in an offline environment
and last but not the least uh cloud
spanner
offered query optimizer versioning
capability to our customers
uh and this is a ga feature so basically
what does it mean
now users have the flexibility to run
their queries with a
specific version of query optimizer
there's a
range of choices which we offer you can
pin your complete database
on a query optimizer version or you can
you can decide to pin just your
application on
a specific query optimizer version with
the default
query optimizer for the database as
being something different so you can
override
the default on the database and finally
you can use a specific query optimizer
version as a query hint as well
and you can test your query with a
specific query optimized version
so there's a range of choices and
flexibility which we offer as part of
this feature
and customers can decide to pin their
application
or the whole database and get that same
predictable performance
from spam so that concludes my
presentation
but as next steps we have a couple of
very interesting
talks uh planned for for spanner so
first we have a talk which one of our
customers
is going to give about switching from
dynamodb to cloud bigtable and spanner
please
tune into that it was a fairly big
undertaking in terms of
migration from dynamo we are talking
terabytes of data and
a lot of throughput in that application
which they migrated
from dynamo onto spanner and big table
and then there's another talk which one
of our gaming specialists is
uh giving about how customers can
modernizing
and modernize their gaming applications
uh with spanner
again to benefit from the scale and
consistency which spanner offers
there's also a showcase demo which has
been planned and there's a quick lab
uh we welcome you to try it out and
learn more about spanner through that
with that
uh thanks a lot thanks for your time and
attention
i really appreciate it and thanks for
using spanner and please reach out to us
if you have any questions
thank you